[Applause]
but the
the ayahuasca ceremony is it's a
ceremony you come you prepare yourself
for multiple days at least three days
vegan
no alcohol like the first time that i
went three days in my life without
eating meat
in my entire life was the three days
before my first ayahuasca ceremony wow
because my you know my father was like
oh mom if you're a real man you have to
eat meat
yeah you know like you eat meat like
this is what i was raised on you know
and why do you have to limit the diet
why do you need strict vegan diet
well it's not even about just vegan it's
just about not having any animals
alcohol especially alcohol drugs um
cheeses any because if you want to come
into the ayahuasca center you want to
come with all your good all your purity
you don't want to come in with
like the the energy of the cow on the
hormones uh
producing the artificial pregnancy milk
that you put into your
you know egg sandwich and then the
turkey bacon yeah the death of the
turkey and then roll into the ayahuasca
ceremony
right that's a lot of emotional trauma
right yeah yeah
yeah i've had people like eat chicken
and go into the ayahuasca ceremony and
experience like the
the death of a chicken for like an hour
and then they never touch chicken the
rest of their life
and they well i've had people i've had
people listening
i'm telling you
okay i had people that that ate meat
yeah right yeah and they think they got
it all figured out right
yeah yeah it's just like with a
girlfriend like you know you like
dinner and massages and then all of a
sudden like after a while you start
getting thinking you're comfortable
yeah yeah right yeah and that's what
people do with ayahuasca like
ayahuasca was saying like mother
ayahuasca like the goddess
yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't know you
better get comfortable you better keep
getting
flowers right so like you keep like bow
your head and reverence
you know so or you know either you give
the respect or she's gonna take it
it's real simple like there's like a
dragon like yeah we're gonna ride a
dragon
yeah yeah i would be like khaleesi like
the dragon
is familiar with me but it's still a
dragon yeah yeah she's allowing you
to ride the dragon that's it yeah you're
not controlling this dress that's the
key
you are you may know her favorite songs
you may know her face what she likes to
dance to the most
right but you're not in control of the
situation you are a maestro
a conductor as the shaman or as the
person taking it no the shaman
the person taking is just laying down
you're just on for the right well you
basically prepare yourself for
at least three days with you know
we have an intake process with my
organization but
basically speaking in broad strokes
three days minimum
no alcohol no animal products no drugs
you come into the ceremony
you don't eat like four hours before you
dress like you're going to
a spiritual sleepover sleeping bag etc
right and you lay down
drink the medicine just lay down that's
it
you can do nothing you sit up you lay
down
nice then the the ayahuasquero and
you know there's songs like i sing in
like five of the native languages from
the amazon so it's just basically like
four five six hours of the most dynamic
shamanic concert experience
imaginable because every little sound
is creating you know every note with the
flute you know there's seven chakras
there's seven notes in major mu
seven major notes in music and seven
colors and so everything is triangulated
into this like
you know five-dimensional situation
that are you painting this journey or
are you awakening
mother nat mother nature okay both and
it's painting itself and you're
guiding it it would be like the
lightning is energy
but then you can move the energy and
light up a whole neighborhood
okay you know tesla style you know okay
so there's lots of you know there's lots
of ways plus it's creating itself
but ultimately like it's good that you
have the fear and the reservation like
but quick quick quick
so so you're creating you're painting
this picture you're creating their
their journey with them as the medicine
is starting to take place
people will start to uh get high for
lack of a better word
uh what do you what word do you use for
so deep people will start to go deep
at different times i imagine
somewhat is it not based on digestive
speed no
no no that's how you know you're dealing
with
but i thought it has to hit the liver
okay so
all at the same time all the logic out
the door okay
so all the same time people are starting
to have these experiences pretty close
to about the same time
are they well one another or you're in a
you're in a trance you're the for the
most part you're no no not necessarily
dude not necessarily trance that's the
thing like you're on your own journey
you're on your own
yes okay so your journey because it's
not a trip that's the thing like
you trip like someone's like oh that was
the most amazing trip i'm like no you
were tripping when you walked in the
door that's why you came here
you know what i mean like you trip when
you're off balance yeah
you trip when you're stuck trying to
stumble upon the truth you stumbled in
here tripping this is a journey you know
a journey is something that's planned
out for purpose
okay now how how much can you take into
that journey
and decide where you go
you are for the most seattle for the
most part
people would describe overall that their
experience is very
interactive with mother ayahuasca
like as if she's not referred to as the
the abuelita you're gonna end up making
me do this [ __ ] bro
we already knew that you wanted that
yeah but you wanted that
you wanted that okay okay god god
go go go go so your experience is
yeah personalized in a way with mother
ayahuasca
in in every imaginable way possible
because
you you know you're basically talking
about like the mother like
we say mother earth right so then
there's the earth component but the
earth is in essence a star with life on
it that's why it's a planet
and that's connected to the universe so
imagine like everything through the
divine feminine is connected to a cosmic
umbilical cord
just like you were connected to your
mother through the umbilical cord in her
stomach
but now we're in the womb of the mother
earth but then we're in the womb of
the cosmic mother at the same time and
and you are
interacting and engaging on every level
not as
hi my name is john i'm 25 years old no
as an eternal being
and so by default you
when you come you know then you're deep
at some point
you come back and you just have that
whole experience that will begin to
unravel itself because if you
if you take someone so deep and they
realize how deep they are while they're
there they're gonna scream
the magic is in when they come back they
realize how deep they were and then they
unpacked that for weeks
does life become boring when you come
back out
that's my first question i have a
follow-up to that no
no of course not do you resent
certain things that exist
in this reality that we're talking in
right now
that you now know to be fake or
fraudulent
since you've existed within the
connectivity
of mother nature and the cosmic
universe etc assuming that that is 100
real and assuming you
really felt that now you go back into
this world where you see people doing
some things you're just like oh you're a
[ __ ] sheep
how do you how do you deal with that
resentment or like maybe anger
yeah that depends on who you are like if
what is your purpose here
like people have goals right but if you
say like someone has goals one year one
month five year 10-year
goals financial goals acquisition of
material possession goals
but if you ask someone what their
purpose is do you know your purpose
i know my purpose and i know my goals so
it's like
when you have the goals that are
beyond crystal clear right and then
purpose you're not really paying so much
attention to
anything else and that's really when you
all your energy you know because every
thought we have is like creating a web
right creating like a thought entity
which is like the thoughts and then you
that rains back down on you that's
karma means action so everything you
draw your attention to you're opening a
portal for that to exist and like reign
back into your field
you know and so when you narrow when you
zoom that back in like a true sorcerer
a whole lot less [ __ ] is coming yeah
yeah but depending on your purpose like
if you're like someone like me yes it's
very difficult to watch people
um you know walk into
the fire yeah i could sense that you
get frustrated with them not with them i
the system
like i can see it's not their fault
because they're blind walking around
but yet at the same time it is it's a
tricky thing that's why i stay in my
house
fair enough so you're so you're
that frustration exists now now after i
went to burning man the first time
i and i had this experience with a
little help from molly
uh i experienced what happened when
my um i was emotionally filled and i had
extra
so like i'm a stand-up comic right i
make people laugh and that probably
stems from the fact that like there's a
little void in me and i'm trying to fill
that void
right so i'm like let me spread some joy
and they're laughing and now i feel good
as well right maybe
maybe maybe maybe something else but
i experienced what it was like to have
that void filled and then
extra and what i did with that extra was
really cool
yeah i just want to give it to people i
wanted to call my friends and tell them
i loved them i want to call my parents
and tell them how grateful i was with
them i really wanted to like share love
right
and i came out of that experience and
for however many months afterwards maybe
i'd be in a conversation with someone
and instead of seeing what i could get
out of that conversation
i was paying attention to what they
might have needed
and i'll be honest with you that's been
really depleted in me yeah but
it was so nice to sit down with someone
and then go oh they really want me to
listen to them and then
give them that gift yeah instead of
going what can i take
yeah from you from 100 percent now i
know it sounds silly to do megapilot by
000. that's what i'm wondering if this
is magnify by 10 000
deeper wider but do you see why i had
that curiosity about course because
you're
a good person but it seems that the
people that have tried this drug
are experiencing somewhat similar things
most people go into ayahuasca completely
for selfish and
reasons i need purpose uh and i'm a
[ __ ] western american
and i want you to make my purpose happen
now listen can i tell you something
funny real quick
so one time i i served medicine like 14
countries
yeah right and so i was talking to this
you know
like a like private client i i never saw
them before
and he was rushing he's like he's like
hello shaman i want to know
if mother ayahuasca will tell me if my
business partner is
[ __ ] my wife and i said that's why
you want to fly me to
this country and serve the medicine
he's like this is good reason and i said
why don't you just hire a private
investigator yeah like
yeah this is not the reason you drink
the ayahuasca you're gonna find
out why you don't trust people yeah
you're gonna fight like maybe find out
why
you you're rolling around with business
partners that you have to worry about
yeah you know and the key is that's what
you're saying the deeper level is
yes even on something that's so
superficial yeah
you know because what kind of business
is he in like you know he's not doing
non-profit yeah trust me you're not
doing non-profits but that's the thing
though like people are drawn to it like
i serve medicine to like i'll have a
ceremony in a location with like
it's nice the tax-free but not non-topic
you know
tax-free and these guys are you know i
attract them i guess but yeah they feel
safe
you know the thing is like you serve
medicine like 10 ptsd
you know people in new york and then
like you'll fly here and serve medicine
on
you know in like a you know 100 million
dollar
freaking mansion in monaco and then next
week you're serving medicine to like a
bunch of yogi
hippies in london and that and they are
serving medicine to like you know
oligarchs
and freaking politicians in for not in
america
yeah foreign countries and then like
everyone imaginable because ultimately
everyone's looking for the same thing
man
everyone wants to know it's gonna be
okay